for this fight I've wrestled with
alligators tussle with the will out on
handcuffed lightning and put Thunder in
jail Cassius Clay exploded onto the
scene in 1960 as the audacious boxer
known as the Louisville lip clay would
change his name and the course of
American history first as an Olympic and
heavyweight champion and in later years
as a civil rights activist and a war
crusader and eventually a beloved figure
who valiantly fought parkinson's disease
i sat down with author Jonathan eye to
discuss his epic new biography of ollie
I'm gonna pull like a butterfly and
sting like a bee him what about Casey
the brash young athlete who emerged in
the early 1960s was quick charismatic
what one writer called Harry Belafonte
with muscles in his new biography ally a
life author Jonathan Ike says the boxer
born Cassius Clay the dyslexic son of an
abusive father was just looking for a
way to fight back and it was boxing
boxing put him in a ring gave him a
chance to punch white people in the face
gave him a chance to prove that he was
bigger and stronger and better than his
father and it gave him a chance to speak
out I am the greatest the phrase I am
the greatest became for the most
important words in the civil rights
movement that alone was a radical act
for a black person to say he was the
greatest and it became a real rallying
cry you see the Black Power movement
adopting that lingering behind those
words said the african-american magazine
evany at the time is a blast furnace of
race pride most of all I'm pretty most
fighters are ugly
in 1964 clay took on heavyweight
champion Sonny Liston almost none of the
sports writers thought he would be
something Liston the only question was
whether he was going to be merely
knocked out or whether he was gonna be
killed they were all wrong and the day
after he beat Liston clay startled the
world again when he announced his
conversion to Islam he was now Muhammad
Ali he had to have known that doing that
was gonna make it challenging for him he
heard it directly from these white
businessmen who were managing his career
they said you're killing us you know we
we had coca-cola offers on the table
after he declared that he wouldn't fight
in Vietnam it got even worse then he was
banned from boxing and and couldn't get
a fight any way against anybody when
would you say that Ali's reputation
changed I think the big change comes in
1971 when he fights Joe Frazier the
fight of the century Madison Square
Garden he's been in exile he was banned
from boxing he was the most hated man in
America and he's finally allowed to
fight again and by now by 1971 our views
on Vietnam have changed and then he goes
in the ring with Joe Frazier and he gets
whupped he gets knocked flat on his book
but and and gets up again and I think
that moment he gets up is the moment
when people begin to feel differently
about Muhammad Ali but the pounding Ali
was taking in the ring according to
Ike's research more than 200,000 punches
over the course of his career was
already taking a toll Ali's own team
started to see it actually quite early
shockingly early his fight doctor his
ring doctor Ferdie Pacheco told me that
he saw damage as early as 1971 this
might be my last fight tonight changes
in his speech in his in his ability to
pay attention and
I saw it after the very first Joe
Frazier fight I worked with scientists
at Arizona State University to study
Ali's speech as an indicator of
cognitive damage from 1970 to 1980 when
he's still fighting at the age of 38 his
speech declines my 26 percent when you
say his speech declines what do you mean
I mean the number of syllables per
second he's got even his own team saw it
why did he keep fighting money he sought
to ally talked about it his his wives
his parents came to him and said we
can't understand what you're saying your
rumbling what's wrong he was concerned
about it but he still kept fighting he's
a mythic figure but he's also a very
human figure you sometimes get the
feeling that he's the Dali Lama the way
the media treated him toward the end and
that wasn't the case he was a deeply
flawed person we don't do him to serve
any any any kind of service by making
him into this 2-dimensional mythic
figure I wanted him to be real I want
readers to understand what he really was
like I can drown the drink of water and
kill a dead tree wait do you see
Muhammad Ali it really is an epic story
and you know so many dimensions you
didn't imagine before Jeff and I
interviewed hundreds of people all of
his surviving ex-wives and what wife and
it's just it's such a complicated
fascinating picture and in a moment when
we're talking about race and sports and
also traumatic brain injuries and the
effects that they have social terms so
timely